[Music]
he's one of the most respected
scientists in the world he's published
over 700 peer-reviewed articles he was
the longest serving chair of the Harvard
astronomy Department his interviews have
been seen by over 10 million people
worldwide but he remains controversial
so Avi I get a little bit pissed off
when you throw the entire scientific
culture under the bus there has to be a
temptation to getting recognition I had
never heard of him until a few years ago
and now I hear about him constantly
today on the occasion of his second book
release Interstellar we take a deep dive
into his claims that he's discovered
evidence from extraterrestrial
technology and will take on the critics
attempting to answer the most important
question ever posed are we alone
welcome Avi how are you doing today
doing great nice to see you again it's
great to have a friend on it's great to
have a brilliant author on you're always
one of my most popular thank you again
well uh fundamentally I'm a farm boy as
you well know and when I went to the
Expedition I bought the private jet and
the pilot as I entered the jet they said
welcome aboard Professor Loeb and I I
said you don't need any titles here just
call me Avi and because fundamentally
I'm just a curious Farm Boy and I say
that to you as well yes I know and uh
there's a lot of a lot of things to
discuss today I'll just say I'm the
first person in my family like you
probably to go and get a PhD in advanced
astrophysics so you know when they say
everything you need to know you learned
in kindergarten it's not true today
we're talking about a phenomenal book
that just came out as of their release
of this video Let's see if I can get my
high speed non-harvard grade cameras to
focus and it is called Interstellar Avi
as you know we have a theme in this very
podcast where we do what is forbidden
since the time of of uh Gutenberg
himself and that is to judge books by
their covers so today I'm going to ask
you to judge for us the what went into
the making of This Book the title The
subtitle and the Beautiful cover art on
this wonderful book well the title is
actually a very good hint as to the
content of a scientific paper that
summarizes the results from the
expedition to retrieve fragments or
sparrows from the depth of the Pacific
Ocean and we can talk more about that
but it relates also to anything that
comes from outside the solar system it's
sort of like our Cosmic Street and this
is the key word that we have to keep in
mind because only over the past decade
we were able to find such packages that
came from outside of our home and at our
doorstep near near Earth and amazingly
enough they do not look similar are to
the rocks that we had seen in our
backyard and therefore they might have
been sent to us by someone we just have
to figure it out and maybe we will find
a postal address that indicates they
came from outside the solar system we
can talk about that in fact as as we're
speaking I'm writing that paper uh that
I'm talking about and I know the content
but I cannot reveal all the details we
can talk about that but they relate to
the postal address and then the subtitle
of this book has to do with the
implications of finding that we have a
neighbor
in our Cosmic environment to the future
of humanity and even the search itself
just like the search for a partner in
life can change you and I believe that
it will be the biggest change uh in the
history of humanity because it will make
us humble perhaps we will realize that
we are all in the same boat that's what
I realized when I went to the Pacific
Ocean with all the team members that
worked this selflessly for the success
of the mission and so my hope is that it
will bring Humanity to a better place
instead of us fighting each other on
this boat that we call Earth uh that is
sailing through the ocean of space we
will realize that there isn't someone
else out there and therefore it makes
sense for us to work together so that
then you know we can explore space and
visit whoever that is yeah uh this this
book has many wonderful Illusions and I
I've enjoyed all of your writing
including your technical writing your
papers your textbook astrobiology
textbook and many other of your writings
you're one of the most prolific authors
I know you're writing a book with your
right hand uh as we speak right now I
understand but I wanted to start with a
with a reference that was made in this
wonderful book to pop culture which is
uh which was just so surprising to me
and it's not giving too much away to say
that this quote demonstrates that you
are very much in tune with popular
culture and you say the following
towards the end you say it may well be
that our still sentient Cosmic neighbor
in the Milky Way galaxy this is speaking
of the possibility of extraterrestrial
civilizations or etcs as you call them
it may be that an Etc chose to swipe us
left while monitoring the daily news on
the universal civilization scale dating
app Avi do you have a Tinder account is
there something I should know about that
your beautiful wife will be shocked to
learn about or your daughters
the answer is I have two daughters yes
by the way I always enjoy
um the latest of of the day rather than
you know I'm not so proud of the fact
that we sent music from the 60s on the
golden record because I believe that
nowadays we have a much better music uh
and um I always get bored by watching
old films so to me the edge of the
Frontiers in anything including music or
science is always exciting and thrilling
and that's what we want to communicate
um and so I use that also in my book but
uh more to the point
um there are ways by which Humanity can
behave better and one of them is you
know right now we are allocating two
trillion dollars a year to military
budgets and then if we just listen to
John Lennon who said imagine all the
people living in peace uh and instead of
relying on John Lennon you know I can
imagine this message coming from outside
from a more intelligent species that is
not wasting resources on fighting each
other on a surface of a rock that they
happen to be born on so if we realize
that it makes more sense for us to work
together and avoid conflicts then we can
we will have a surplus of two trillion
dollars a year that we can use to send a
probe to every star in the Milky Way
galaxy within this Century that's what I
calculated so it's actually you know if
you ask what would bring us most
Prosperity the first thing is that we
will start working with each other
rather than fighting each other and that
includes not just
fights between nations but also within a
nation when you know when I jog every
morning and I do it at Sunrise I see
signs in the yards of my neighbors and
they always say the same thing because
they post them because they expect their
neighbors to agree with them but
actually the actual challenge is to post
a sign that you know your neighbors do
not agree with so I can imagine my
neighbors going to another neighborhood
and living there and they would probably
be very cautious at putting at the same
sign and I say that's actually the
foundation of a democracy the foundation
of I would argue also the culture of
universities the academic culture where
people should engage with those who do
not agree with them rather than the
other way and we tend to segregate
towards Drive and that is also of course
assisted by the media people read the
news that are that agree with their
views and uh the reporters are trying to
tune the news to their liking so it's
more of a commercial product rather than
a description of reality and
unfortunately that brings us to a bad
place where there is huge polarization a
faction of society believes that they
are not being attended to you know a
fraction outside Academia for example
and there is this tendency to argue that
Academia is part of the elite and I
don't agree with that because I came
from a farm you know and I believe that
I'm no different than any other person
I'm just curious and I've been given the
privilege of following my curiosity
independently of what other people say
yeah it's interesting you mentioned that
uh the street signs I you know I too
live in a neighborhood just like you
with a lot of trump signs so it's it's
very uh unsurprised no I imagine these
are signs we believe in science we stand
with Ukraine
Etc so I always say yeah put a I stand
with Israel or put a sign up you know
this is Trump country and you'll see how
how they agree with you in such a
neighborhood as Cambridge or Boston but
well you mentioned the Voyager disc and
we have in the book A mention of
andrewian who is quite spectacular and
she's actually been a guest on the show
many years ago along with her daughter
Carl uh Sasha Sagan they're both uh Carl
Sagan's uh relatives the late great Carl
saying Carl Sagan makes an appearance in
this book as well many many times and I
wanted to start there because when we
see claimed often extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence which is
attributed to Carl Sagan I don't know
about you Avi but when I'm studying the
cosmic microwave background or I'm
looking for a primary deal magnetic
fields and radio telescope data I don't
have like a special drawer you know that
says extraordinary evidence you know
pull here there's just evidence so what
do you make of that quote which appears
in this book is there such a thing as
extraordinary evidence or is it just
like when people say it's logical sense
I mean that's kind of redundant as I saw
it no I I do think that it's all about
the evidence and the quality of the
evidence but uh when people make that
statement and by the way Sagan advocated
for it uh unfortunately they're not
seeking the evidence it's a circular
argument and my response is that
extraordinary evidence requires
extraordinary funding and Carl Sagan was
actually Junior faculty in my department
several decades before I arrived uh he
lived in my town uh in Massachusetts
near Harvard then and um you know I I do
appreciate the fact that he was a
Pioneer at his time that people did not
believe in studying the kind of things
that he was advocating for but I just
don't think that this argument brings us
to a good place because you can argue
also that dark matter is an
extraordinary claim we haven't seen it
but nevertheless we invested billions of
dollars trying to find what it is we
haven't witnessed it in the solar system
we believe it exists because we see that
there might you know gravity is much
stronger than you can associate with
matter that we can see but it's also
possible that gravity is modified okay
and for some reason the mainstream of
cosmologist fell to the notion that the
dark matter is a set of particles we
haven't seen yet and we invested you
know the most popular was the lightest
supersymmetric particle we looked for
supersymmetry with a Large Hadron
Collider at an investment of 10 billion
dollars and guess what we haven't found
it okay so was that a waste of money was
that Mis an extraordinary claim that
should not have been attended to no we
tried to find the evidence we invested
huge sums of money we didn't find it so
if we are pursuing a theoretical idea
because it looks compelling or because
the implications are large it's not
because we already have evidence for it
it's because we find this intriguing and
exciting it's like a detective story try
to figure it out and there is nothing
more exciting than trying to figure out
if we are alone okay and in that context
I would argue we should invest billions
of dollars in that search rather than
pushing it aside and saying it's
extraordinary to think that we have
Partners I think it's the other way
around I think it's arrogant to think
that we are alone and we should invest
in in the search and you know if we were
to invest billions of dollars for the
next uh several decades we would be and
not find anything in the worst case
scenario we would be at exactly the same
point as dark matter searches are right
now so you can't on the one hand say oh
Dark Matter searches are part of the
mainstream while at the same time say
searching for partners like us because
we know that we exist is actually Fringe
signs you can't say that why because
most of the public cares more about
whether we have any Cosmic neighbors and
if you are using taxpayers money
actually the right thing to do is invest
more in the second question and that's
not the situation right now and you know
I feel that it's even worse than that
that in the mainstream of particle
physics of theoretical particle physics
you have people contemplating ideas that
have no foundation in experiments we
don't know if there are extra Dimensions
we don't don't like string theory is the
right direction at all but yet we are
engaged in it for four decades and there
is a whole community of people working
on mathematical gymnastics and why is
that legitimate why would you call that
an ordinary claim that requires the
attention of a thousand people in
mathematical physics it's not obvious at
all that this is physics and yet you
have
popularizes of science claiming that
it's the frontier physics so I just see
those circumstances as Academia not
being
honest okay and honesty is saying
anything that is not a result of
experimental data is a theoretical
concept and we can evaluate the
significance of it by the implications
that it will have if we find one thing
or another and you know using this
metric I think that the search for
partners Cosmic Partners is should be
our highest priority so this is a
statement about such
just Titanic Revelations that could be
possibly revealed uh by you and other
team members on the Galileo project that
you founded in direct and it's a
stunning headline Harvard scientist uh
which is the way you're always described
says he may have proof of alien life in
a new study and it says quote we should
welcome it professor avilob said his
full paper would likely be released in
the next month Avi can you break this
news now are you prepared to break this
news or should our my audience uh wait
patiently for it as you said the public
has a right to know it's their money
it's their data not in the case of this
particular Mission because that's
privately funded but the the notion
stands as you said exactly people are
more generally interested in the
lightest uh partner in this in the
universe than they are uh intelligent
partner in the universe than they are on
the lightest supersymmetric particle in
the Periodic Table of subatomic
particles tell us Avi what can you say
about this uh shocking claim
so let me explain the context I'm a
theoretical astrophysicist meaning I'm a
person of ideas yet I see that nobody is
pursuing the subject that we talked
about experimentally which should be the
way that science uh gains new knowledge
I mean we can think of ideas but most
importantly we should check whether they
match reality and so I decided to lead
an expedition to the Pacific Ocean to
find the relics of the first recognized
Interstellar meteor so let me break it
down a meteor is an object that collides
with Earth and burns up in the
atmosphere of Earth generating a
fireball similar to an atomic explosion
if the size of this object is the size
of a person roughly the amount of energy
released is roughly the energy released
by the Hiroshima atomic bomb
and obviously the context of that can be
seen in the latest movie Oppenheimer but
of course there are many more objects
smaller than that size and fewer objects
larger and we know that an object the
size of Manhattan Island uh collided
with Earth 66 million years ago and
basically decimated the most life forms
including the dinosaurs so we want to
know more about how many objects collide
with Earth but what happened almost a
decade ago in 2014 the U.S government
satellites which are monitoring Earth
for National Security threats such as
ballistic missiles notice the Fireball
from a meteor
of an object roughly at least half a
meter in size the one unusual fact about
this meteor was that it was moving very
fast and translating the measured
velocity by the US government satellites
to the velocity of the object relative
to the sun we realize together with my
undergraduate student at the time Amir
siraj after I asked him to go through
the catalog and look at the fastest
objects we realized this object actually
was moving faster than the Escape speed
the speed necessary to escape from the
solar system so that means that it came
from outside the solar system it was not
bound gravitationally to the Sun and
also we calculated it outside the solar
system it was moving at 60 kilometers
per second relative to the local frame
of the Galaxy the local standard of rest
and that's faster than 95 percent of all
stars in the vicinity of the Sun and
moreover from the fireball data that was
released by the US government a few
years later there was a letter from the
U.S space command to NASA saying indeed
we confirmed this assertion that the
object was Interstellar at the 99.99
confidence we calculated from the data
on the fireball that it was tougher than
all space rocks cataloged by NASA over
the past decade 272 of them and the way
we concluded that is because the stress
exerted on the object by air was the
highest before it disintegrated it was
able to maintain its Integrity to very
high Ram pressures and that implies that
it's made of materials tougher than even
iron meteorites so what is it I mean one
obvious thought that came to my mind is
that it could be a voyager like meteor
just imagine another civilization
sending Voyager like spacecraft and
within some billions of years it could
sides with Earth and it will appear as a
meteor but of unusual material strength
because it's made of stainless steel and
unusual speed because it was propelled
by a chemical
rocket to start with so this led me to
organize this Expedition and it cost one
and a half million dollars which were
donated by Charles hoskinson and we
rented a ship that was fittingly called
Silver Star and we went there to the
meteor site the U.S Department of
Defense localized it within a seven mile
region and within that region we were
able to even narrow down the path of the
meteor to within another mile or so in
terms of the width by a factor of 10
using data from a seismometer on Manus
Island in Papua New Guinea which
happened to be about 70 or 60 to 70
miles away from that location station so
we went there and we designed a magnetic
sled with basically a sled that weighs
200 kilograms has a width of roughly a
meter and we attached magnets on both
sides and we dragged it across lines of
10 kilometers in size or seven miles in
in length and we went back and forth and
the first um we wanted to collect of
course magnetic particles from that
meteor and at first we did not collect
anything because uh the cable that
connected the sled to the ship lifted it
and it was kiting
and so we managed to solve that problem
we had an exceptional team of really
high level professionals the best in the
world and they realized that going with
the current of the ocean allows us to
keep the sled on the floor and then
after the second day we started
collecting materials most of the
materials were volcanic ash black powder
but among them we were able to filter
out using a mesh
the tiny volcanic particles let them go
and and we were left with bigger
particles and once we put them under a
microscope we realized that we have some
molten droplets from the surface of the
meteor because they looked very distinct
from the background now it's a constant
level in that now Avi I know that the
trajectory is over five nines confidence
level but what's the confidence level
that the actual spheroes you have came
from the meteor itself right so the
important thing is
we went back and forth like 26 times so
we crisscrossed that region of seven
miles in size and amazingly enough we
found the concentration of the spherols
per amount of background that we
collected from the ocean floor to be
just along the meteor path so we found
twice as many spheroes along the meteor
path as we found everywhere else per
amount of mass collected of magnetic Ash
magnetic particles and the fact that it
coincided I mean we had control regions
far away we also had control regions
around the meteor path and the fact that
the yield of spherols was doubled along
the meteor path gave us an initial
initial confidence that it is related
okay but then most importantly we
analyze the composition of these
spherols and I should say on the ship we
had a an instrument to do that an x-ray
analyzer which was blind to some
elements but it indicated that most of
the material is iron but when we came
back we've I mean over the on the ship
we found about 50s ferals uh so you know
and we had limited time but once I
brought the sample back I had a summer
intern named Sophie Bergstrom who was
supposed to Shadow me because she wants
to become a science journalist and she
wanted to see how the science is done
and I invited her to spend the summer
and then she told me at some point that
if she can be helpful she'll be glad to
participate in the science and I
arranged the tweezers and a microscope
for her and she went over the samples
that we collected and she found 650 news
ferals so that's more than a factor of
10 above the number that we found on the
ship amazingly enough we that allowed us
to do the statistics much better as I um
and and we concluded what I mentioned
before with the map that we created but
now we had a lot of spheroes to examine
at the Harvard University and I shared
materials with University of California
at Berkeley with the broker Corporation
in Germany and with the University of
Technology in Papua New Guinea but as of
now we did the most detailed analysis at
Harvard University
in the laboratory of Stein Jacobson who
is a world recognized expert on such
matters and so the first question that
we are attempting to answer and you will
see the results in the paper is the
material composition in terms of
elements and radioactive isotopes
um is that consistent with solar system
materials or not is it Interstellar in
origin and we have a clear answer to
this question and I cannot uh reveal it
you'll come back on hopefully and we'll
do a a quick quick interview about that
but let me ask you a question since
presumably you know other solar systems
have their formation origin stories as
you like to talk about uh then they must
have some things in common with ours and
the question I would have is if they
also originated from the internal
Collision perhaps within a solar system
uh of of two Rocky heavy objects with
some kind of metallic high density cores
how could you distinguish that one you
know it's not going to come tagged with
you know Maiden made in uh you know
solar system you know a it's going to
have exactly you know because they all
originated from a from a supernova type
2 probably are you correct me if I'm
wrong type 2 Supernova eventually that
produced iron and a nickel so how could
you actually assay as Galileo would call
it how would you ask say the difference
between the actual metallic types in
order to tag it geotag it or unit Cosmo
tag it the star that exploded in a
different region of the Milky Way galaxy
was probably of a different mass and the
yields were different but most
importantly the planet if it's a natural
object that was formed from materials on
the planet far away uh you know may have
had a different history uh of uh you
know the amount of time it spent in
molten phase and then with materials
segregating in it what I can tell you is
we have a very clear signal and this
signal cannot be confused with solar
system and the details are to be shown
in the paper the point is the periodic
table is not just iron and a few
elements around it there are lots of
elements and you can create a very
distinct finger fingerprint when you
look at the entire periodic table
that is that deviates significantly from
the solar system composition because
everything in the solar system came from
the same gas cloud that was enriched by
a nearby star that exploded and it
shares very similar patterns including
in terms of the ratio of Isotopes and so
it's not just the elemental bonuses but
but also Isotopes and while I cannot
elaborate all I can say is that there is
a way of clearly differentiating between
Interstellar origin and solar system
origin and the details are to be seen in
the paper now of course the second the
second important question that you
alluded to is whether it's technological
in origin and that's uh you know
obviously if you imagine an object like
Voyager that collided with earth and its
surface was molten you know you would
expect different abundance patterns
because it was made of stainless steel
and the same is true with semiconductors
or computer screens if they melt you
would see some very very unusual
signatures yeah I mean could you say I
know you have to wait for the paper but
could you say something about the alloy
composition yeah so all we can at this
point can do is examine the abundances
of different elements on in the periodic
table I mean in principle one can do
reverse engineering one can take those
elements that we find at the abundances
that we find put them together in a
laboratory and check the material
strength and see what it gives you I
would argue that irrespective whether
it's technological or not it's already a
historic finding if we demonstrate that
it's Interstellar because it's the first
time that humans put their hands on the
materials from a big object that came
from outside the solar system never
before unless David grush is telling the
truth and the US government has it
already but I haven't seen it well
that's my uh that's my next question Avi
actually now you and I talked uh just
you know briefly after the uh the events
of the testimony I've had on Ryan Graves
who did testify as you know and um and
because of that I think you know I think
it's interesting to my audience to get a
sense of from you as an external person
to the field of you know pilots and
witnessing extra solar uh potential
extra solar system technology and even
as it says here non-human biological
material now that's pretty wide I
remember zeldovic I think said although
you'll know better than me said you know
when you call something non-something
it's like saying that's a non-dog animal
it's it's too it's too broad right Avi
but tell me what did you make of
Grocer's testimony it was shot
um unfortunately he did not have access
to any of the evidence any of the
materials and he just spoke with 40
people
that told him a story and of course the
good news is that he conveyed the
contact information of those people to
Congress people who asked for it during
the hearing so that implies that within
the coming months hopefully they'll
follow on and contact those people and
can get to the bottom of it and the
question is where are the materials held
if this is true and can we get access to
those materials if they are held by
corporations they might not be easy to
access I mean there is a legislation
proposed for December in the defense
bill that the committee of nine people
will have authority to ask for those
materials or information about them from
outside government this this would be a
committee under the president and that
would be interesting as well to see what
comes out from that hook you know
whether it catches any fish the point
about the corporations if they hold the
material evidence is that it's just like
the relationship between a psychiatrist
and a patient a psychiatrist never
solves the problem of the patient
because otherwise the payment will stop
you know and the same is true about
corporations that get funded by the
Department of Defense and my personal
trainer my personal trainer is like that
too
keeps giving me pizza after every
repetition
all the dentist always has chocolates in
the reception
um so um my point is this any such data
should be released openly to the uh to
to the science community so that we can
get to the bottom of what it means and
the reason is simple because anything
that came from Interstellar space you
know it doesn't adhere to National
borders because it started the journey
probably before humans existed and so
whoever sent it doesn't care how we
split the land it shouldn't be a matter
of National Security uh it should be
information shared by all humans which
is basically science and I very much
hope that if there is anything it will
be shared with Scientists like me that
would be happy to help government figure
it out but it's also possible that the
story is fabricated until you see the
evidence you never know people have
motivations for inventing storylines
that I mean obviously when you have a
car accident people involved provide
very different reports thoughts that's
why the World Cup Women's World Cup
uses cameras to infer whether there was
a goal or not and the U.S team was
kicked out Based on data from a video
camera not based on what the players
said or the audience said so that's the
way science should be done and not based
on what people say to grash or what
grash understood from the stories that
he had it needs to be substantiated by
evidence and until we see the evidence
we don't know but I want to push back on
you if you could uh repeat what you said
that famous phrase that you used when we
spoke with Gary Nolan about a year ago
and I hope to have Gary on again with
you
um but but you could repeat what you
said please the sky is not classified
the oceans are not classified
and therefore we have an opportunity to
figure out the truth without relying on
government to tell it to us and that is
my Approach as a scientist I think it's
possible that we will learn what lies
outside the solar system by figuring out
the composition of the swirls uh at the
bottom of the Pacific Ocean it's a depth
of more than a mile then waiting for
politicians in Washington DC to tell us
I want to push back as you know with
love and respect um I think some cases
this guy might be classified and
sometimes the the ocean needs to be
classified I mean after all I can't go
down to San Diego Harbor and cruise off
the coast where my friend Jocko willink
who who sent me this bottle of malc
brought it to me when he came over once
you know I could just go there and say
hey seals how you doing let's uh let's
go play and let me look at those
dolphins with the uh with the football
helmets filled with MRI cameras and it
is classified for our security I want to
take us back you talk a lot a lot about
my my hair of science Galileo and he's
your hero too I know that and Galileo
you know pushed back against the
equivalent of you know the world
government at the time which was the
Catholic church and they to some extent
had an obligation to provide not only
for the dissemination of scientific
information okay maybe that's their goal
maybe that's not their goal but at some
level governments have an obligation to
ensure life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness meaning that they have an
obligation to pursue peace and to
provide peace on Earth now that
sometimes might mean according to some
that we don't reveal all of our national
secrets you know the the kind of data
that's collected by a kh1 uh kh11 spy
satellite it's about the same quality as
the Hubble Space Telescope as you know
way better than me but tell me Avi don't
governments have some obligation to keep
some things uh hidden from their
population I mean can you can you make
the argument that some information can
you can you envision information a
discovery may be made by you or or some
are your competitors you that would be
so traumatic for the infant Earth after
all that the aliens won't swipe left on
us what can you imagine the case for
actually segregating information
classifying data from the sky I think
that is a misguided approach because it
resembles going out to your backyard uh
when your family was isolated since you
were born and and then you go check the
rocks in your backyard and suddenly you
notice a tennis ball that was thrown by
a neighbor now you are facing a dilemma
will you bring the news back to your
family which obviously will create some
Shock and because they always were under
the belief that they are isolated nobody
is around or will you maybe keep it
secret and my uh uh this decision would
have been uh to definitely share it with
my family because some family members
might want to at that point um uh close
off the curtains to maintain privacy or
maybe step outside and greet the
neighbor and learn something new by
speaking to the neighbor on where they
came from what insights they have or the
neighbor might show up at your front
door one day so you can't avoid it or
the neighbor might influence your life
and indirectly it's part of the reality
that you live in with your family and
you have to share that information and
the same holds for our Cosmic
neighborhood because you know it will
change our perspective about our place
in the universe uh it would affect our
aspirations for space this is science
science is knowing what the universe is
like and you cannot filter science you
cannot just say this is knowledge that
should be hidden because that's what the
church wanted to do in the case of
Galileo well they didn't want his view
that you know maybe the Earth is not at
the center of the universe to be known
to the public and so they wanted to
suppress that and obviously it's not the
right approach because now we leave it
at the Space Age and if we were to
continue to maintain the view of not
letting the public know about it and we
would design our space missions based on
the assumption that the Earth is at the
center of the solar system we would
never reach Mars because Mars doesn't
move around the earth uh and you know I
think it's our duty to attend to the
facts of the reality that we live in
even if it's not flattering even if we
look at the mirror and see pimples on
our face we should not put makeup
because we want to figure out you know
what the reality is and that's what
science brings to the table it brings us
a better sense of reality you might say
okay well we have some sense of reality
but it's
Shallow by using the methods of science
we can get much deeper understanding of
where we live and what to do about it
and you know that includes figuring out
that the sun will die uh one day and we
will have to move out of Earth if we
want to survive as a civilization it
also includes the mitigation of global
warming if we can do that uh it includes
anything Global the you know realizing
what the risks from AI might be to
society anything to do with the reality
that we live in you know is really
essential it's the bread and butter for
our survival because we need to adapt to
it we need to if we deny it uh you know
if the dinosaurs didn't obviously they
didn't look up they didn't have
telescopes and they could have denied
this rock approaching them because they
didn't want to collect any data they
were very proud of their existence and
look what happened to them that's not a
fate that we want to imitate
yeah they had a Galileo project that
wouldn't have happened speaking of
pimples by the way speaking about
Galileo I should tell you that um it's
also I was asked them recently do I
believe in God and I my reply was it
depends what you mean by that obviously
I do believe that there is a more
advanced technological civilization that
is could be a good approximation to God
and when you look at the Old Testament
and you find a story like Moses seeing
the burning bush you know with a Galileo
project that I'm leading could have
assisted Moses because that was a
turning moment for him to realize that
maybe there is a superhuman entity based
on the fact that the Bush was burning
and never consumed and of course with
the Galileo project infrared sensors we
could have informed Moses on the
temperature of the Bush the amount of
energy emitted during the time and could
have advised Moses whether you know it's
a natural phenomena or a phenomena
gender created by superhuman entity but
as to whether it's a God in the
traditional sense or perhaps a high
higher level technological entity that
remains to be seen
well I don't want to get to Art Bell on
you but he did mention uh the Torah the
Old Testament so I can't resist asking
you this question there are some that
speak of what are called the Nephilim uh
which you can uh you could probably talk
about better than me did you ever read
that story and uh have any kind of um uh
reaction to it there's a story about
Giants there were the Mighty Men the men
of renown but they're described as
Giants in the Hebrew obviously me
telling you about Hebrew is is kind of
like me telling you about theoretical
astrophysics how do you interpret that I
mean obviously literally uh there are
giants you know compared to you know
someone who's a little person as they're
called nowadays
um but what what does that mean to you
this concept of uh the Nephilim the
Giants Well it's interesting and there
are other stories in the Bible about you
know about the entities that could have
you know done Miracles that were not
fully understood uh angels and stuff
like that and it is possible in
principle that there was an encounter
with some technological gadgets that
people misinterpreted as you know
superhuman entity we don't know because
we don't have the data it's just like
the reports at the House of
Representatives uh where the pilots were
telling us what they saw you know it's
eyewitness testimony and it looks
intriguing but you know it's not
sufficient to assess what it means and
the same is true about obviously
historic uh evidence that was reported
by humans humans are not good detectors
and unfortunately we can't go back to
the Biblical times and check what really
happened so we just need to think
forward uh to to look forward and you
know the one thing I I hope is that if
we encounter something that came from
far away that is far more advanced than
we are that could be the Messiah you
know that it will make Humanity better
it will bring up more first future we
tend to think especially within Judaism
that the Messiah was born on Earth will
be born on Earth or was born already I
mean depending on which sect you are I
mean obviously there are some people in
Brooklyn that believe that the Messiah
was born there and we come back the
point is maybe the true story of the
Messiah is that it's extraterrestrial
because once we have an encounter with a
superhuman entity it will inspire all in
all humans and uh similar to religious
law and it will make us humble and
realize that you know we can reach a
more prosperous future and that sort of
are the signatures of a Messianic era
and so my hope is that we will have it
in our lifetime
Rabbi uh
speaking of Brooklyn uh which is in
Manhattan I want to uh show you well
first of all I want to show you this
article headline uh in the New York
Times the the paper of record after the
San Diego Union Tribune and uh it's it's
not altogether flat watering but one
thing I always want to point out because
you know you must know that you are
controversial in some circles that
people whether it's jealousy whether
it's people that are envious of your
success of your Renown uh they are
snarky they attack you
um and there is a whole cohort of people
you're not on Twitter which explains why
you can write so many wonderful books
but I am and sometimes I forward you
stuff from various Outlets there's a
whole underground network of people that
love to would like to see you fall and
they'd like to see uh this experience of
schadenfreude be materialized whether
whether for their own psychological
needs or you know maybe there's some
truth to it uh at some level but I I
wonder you know you don't let that
affect you and and part of that is is
very refreshing to me because I I find I
do get troubled sometimes by people
attacking me on the internet and maybe I
should spend you know less time on it is
is the message but one of the things I
want to point out to people is that um
Avi is a scientist a thorough scientist
meaning that I pointed out things that
in a lesser sort of intellect a more
thin-skinned person uh would would
probably cause a negative reaction maybe
compromise friendship but I knew I could
point out to you the various typos and
things that I found and not only did you
not you know attack me and be defensive
you were like oh thank you I'll take
care of that like uh and I think that's
a sign of a of a great scientist and so
I want to commend you for that thank you
and I should say for example I wrote 43
diary reports during the Expedition yeah
and on the sixth day I basically said
where are the spheroles
so I was admitting that we haven't found
what we were looking for and that it
could be a failure the mission can be a
failure and I was doing it sincerely and
gladly the following day we found the
first feral so what I'm trying to say is
I'm as honest as I can and some people
you know I think they're motivated
mainly by jealousy uh and they
um for example attacked me for writing
about this scientific Expedition because
they said you should have waited until
you got the results and reported them in
a scientific paper and I say no because
the public sees it as a detective story
and they like detective sorry so I show
how science is done where you can make
mistakes along the way and eventually
the evidence should guide you and I see
that as an educational exercise for
showing the the public how science is
done and a lot of people thanked me for
that there was one person who said you
know I had a stroke a few weeks ago and
reading your diet very reports gave me
strength to live and you know that's
very moving so I connect to the public
this way but I also use it as a teaching
moment for my colleagues in Academia
because they forgot what science is
about it's not about showing off it's
not about saying we are always right and
here is what we found as if there are
lectures in a class they talk down to
the public no it's not about that it's
about showing that the scientific
inquiry is work in progress It's done by
iterations there are mistakes along the
way and eventually evidence should
convince us just like a detective
looking for the explanation so that is
the most important thing and I think you
know and then the approach that I take
to those people who attack me by now
after having so much experience you know
I had more than 3 000 interviews over
the past two two years and the best
approach is that of the eagle you know
the eagle often has a crow on his back
and the crow is the only bird that can
sit on the back of an eagle and pack at
the Eagle's neck and so the approach of
the eagle is not to fight off the crow
but to rise to Greater Heights where the
oxygen level is low so that the crow
drops off the back of the eagle and for
me it's exactly that method rising to
the highest level of science is the way
to get my critics off my back so that
they will stop pecking at my neck and
doing the signs in the best possible way
is collecting the evidence bringing the
materials back and analyzing it you know
and on the day that I came from the
Expedition there was a scientific paper
published in the astrophysical journal
saying the government measured the wrong
velocity it's actually three times
smaller this object is made of stone the
meteor that I was seeking It's Made of
Stone and the US government doesn't know
what they're talking about and moreover
the data must be wrong because otherwise
we can't fit it with with a model for a
stone so what I wanted to say I held
them at this ferals from that meteor in
my hands at that time and I knew that
they're made mostly of iron
so I knew the paper is wrong but why
would anyone publish India astrophysical
Journal a paper when that person knows
that I'm going on an expedition to find
them why not just wait it just shows you
that the negativity is motivated by
something else I prefer to believe that
it has nothing to do with the fact that
I'm Jewish yeah but the other thing I I
wanted to say uh is that just yesterday
you know there is a new profile that
will be cover story in the New York
Times magazine about my research coming
out in a week and as part of the fact
checking I had a conversation yesterday
about
um you know there was a model that was
proposed several months ago that was
published in nature that in fact
the first reported Interstellar object
the size of a football field that had a
non-gravitational acceleration was just
a water iceberg that was transformed by
cosmic rays into hydrogen and oxygen
broken I mean the molecules were broken
off and and then the hydrogen provided
it with propulsion that was observed as
the non-gravitational acceleration when
it came close to the Sun and what we
showed a day after this paper was
published is that they made a huge
mistake in the energy equation there is
a term that is millions of times bigger
than the terms that they included and
that is cooling by the evaporation of
hydrogen the fact that you need to
disloy the hydrogen atoms from the
surface of this iceberg is taking away
some of the energy that the surface
receives from the Sun okay and that at
the temperature that they calculated by
omitting this cooling of more than 100
degrees above absolute zero this term is
actually millions of times bigger than
the other terms so clearly a mistake
on that day I wrote to all the reporters
that they talked about celebrated the
success of this nature paper and I said
look they made a mistake in the energy
equation and I heard back from one
reporter who said oh um we don't want to
confuse our readers we will not make any
amendment to our report and I I said you
don't need to say anything other than
avilob uh you know just wrote a paper
that disputes the energy calculation but
anyway they decided not then another
reporter said I approached the authors
of the original paper and they told me
that they are not willing to make any
comment about your paper until it's
refereed and I said fine then we waited
a few months the paper was referred and
accepted for publication with the same
content I came back to that reporter
never heard back okay so it's not it's
more about conveying the message that
maybe a lot of people want to hear which
is maybe it was just a what author
Iceberg rather than doing the math
correctly and what happened when in the
fact checking is the reporter involved
in the story in the New York Times
magazine about my career was telling me
you know I tried to approach the authors
of that paper and I couldn't get a
comment from them after your paper is
already accepted for publication and
published but I reached out to another
expert on the subject and that expert
said in this equation there is a term
that should have been could have been
considered as time dependent whereas in
the equation it was considered this
constant
And the reporter said
does that actually change your
conclusion because that person said that
you can't trust the result and I said
this term needs to be millions of times
smaller so if you change a coefficient
that is of all the unity by a factor of
a few even by a factor of a hundred it
would not make this mistake go away you
need to change it to bring it down by a
factor of millions and and I said look
at figure one we are showing that we are
showing that the term that was omitted
uh was much bigger than anything else at
the temperature that they calculated
therefore the temperature must be much
smaller to me it illustrates the
following fact that the so-called expert
wanted to raise enough dust so that they
can claim that they can't see anything
it has nothing to do with substance that
expat did not put a Time depends because
that expert if they were to put a time
difference they would realize
immediately that it doesn't solve the
problem because you need to reduce that
term by millions and just to show you
that people are trying to tackle me in
any possible way they are not doing the
math correctly and they are just making
claims that are not substantiated and I
should say you know I'm still down to
the trenches I'm doing my research I'm
not a blogger I'm actually doing
scientific research publishing in
scientific journals so that's the way I
deliberate especially you know kind of
uh odious to me was a claim made by
Steve Dash in this article uh who is an
astrophysicist at Arizona State
University he says people are sick of
hearing about avilob's wild claims well
I think Avi uh the multi-million seller
of of your first book and and your
appearance is one of the most popular
guests on Lex Friedman and Joe Rogan Etc
you know Bill is that puts the light of
that fact people are not sick of it
they're very interested he goes on to
say something I think is is very it's
almost mendacious it says it's polluting
good science conflating the good science
we do with this ridiculous
sensationalism sucking out all the
oxygen from the room then he says Dr
Dash added that several of his
colleagues were now refusing to engage
with Dr loeb's work in peer review The
process by which Scholars evaluate one
another's research to ensure that only
high quality studies are published it's
a real breakdown of the peer review
process and the scientific method he
said it's so demoralizing and tiring Avi
who's breaking down who is the one who's
undermining this and who are the people
that say we should only trust things
that are peer reviewed and now they're
saying we refuse to peer review it
that's empathetical Mr Desh or Dr Dash I
actually don't know who he is but I'd be
willing to have him on and I'd love to
talk to him to get an impression from
him because uh Professor Dash if that's
what he is I think that you're
completely out of line to say that you
won't even peer review that's a bare
minimum for a scientist and to say you
won't engage with data once it's
submitted that's almost as if you are
evoking this index of forbidden books
from the time Galileo and Bruno what say
you Avi yeah what I say is I I never
wish the dash to be sick I wish him
prosperity and good health and any
sickness that he encounters should be
discussed with his therapist you know I
remember we had a junior faculty member
in our department decades ago and you
know everyone believes in dark matter
being particles and there was a paper
published about perhaps gravity is
modified
in the context of some modified
Newtonian Dynamics
and that person
was sick of hearing about this
alternative and I asked you why would
you be so emotional about a completely
logical possibility you know if we see
that gravity cannot be accommodated by
known matter there are two possibilities
either you know the law of gravity is
modified which is a possibility or there
is matter and the only way to address
the the choice between these two
possibilities is uh by trying to find
proof for one or the other and it
shouldn't make you sick to consider an
alternative why would anyone be upset
and emotional it's only because that
person is a True Believer in one of the
possibilities but that's more the realm
of Faith you know of religions of Cults
uh it's not the realm of Science in
science we should be guided by evidence
and we should discuss in a very
collegial way why the evidence does not
support one possibility versus the other
but if there is no evidence if the
evidence is intriguing if there are
anomalies the discussion should be open
and I came from this culture of trying
to figure out the dark matter in
cosmology and I know that a lot of
people suggested
ideas that are out of the box and that
was actually encouraged as a young
person I got a tenure while working on
such issues you know at Harvard
University where they didn't tenure for
15 years before me uh and the point is
it's we don't know something so we are
trying to think about possible
explanations and then we examine them
experimentally that's the scientific
method but you can't say I will never
referee a paper that suggests that the
dark matter is an Axion and not a weakly
interacting massive particle because I
made a peer review and Avi I won't even
peer review it that's what he's saying
yeah and that is completely opposite to
the scientific method to the openness of
mind that should be accompanying Blue
Sky research and I say you know these
people who claim to protect science are
actually not representing science they
are opposite to the scientific method
because all I did was say maybe this
meteor came from outside the solar
system based on the government and data
I respected the data from the US
government because the U.S space command
is the organization paid more than NASA
to figure out if there are any national
security threats and if they were wrong
by a factor of three in the case of this
Fireball then I would never sleep at
night because I would say you know tens
of billions of dollars are allocated to
an organization that advises President
Biden about ballistic missiles I would
say you know that's what they're saying
in the scientific paper in the
astrophysical journal as of a couple of
months ago that's exactly what they were
saying that that the U.S space command
doesn't know what they are talking about
but I said I don't argue with that I
respect the U.S space command I say I
trust you I will go there and check if I
find materials I go there and you know
what happened a few months before I went
there I was invited to give a lecture
where at Arizona State University okay
and the person who invited me said that
we would very much like to hear about
your forthcoming Expedition and the
person who invited me is a very
distinguished physicist that I respect
greatly
and I said you're sure I'll be delighted
to give this
and then half a day before he told me
your host will be Steve Dash
and I said I'm conveying as we say I
said I'm not giving this talk I don't
feel safe in the company of this person
because I know what he's saying and I
said here is a solution for you in order
not to disappoint your audience
please ask
Steve Dash to give the talk instead of
me about umwa and he said great I'll ask
him because you can you're declining I
said yeah please give him the floor as a
result
Steve Dash gave the talk in which he
said explicitly that I will not find
anything in this expedition to the
Pacific Ocean he said that explicitly on
video recorded publicly now I went there
I found materials someone came to me
and said them you know uh can you give
me an example of a person who criticizes
the Expedition because now you found it
and I was you know I witnessed what you
found and it looks very convincing
um I said yeah please go to that video
where Steve Dash says
that you will not find any that I would
not find anything and now it's not only
documented thanks to the fact that I
gave in the floor but it will also
appear in a documentary well they say
living well is the best revenge Avi let
me ask you this what I would say what I
would say is that bullying has a price
as I said I I never heard of him
um that's not that says more about me
than it says about him but nevertheless
the fact that he's claiming multiple
people I wonder how you know his Arizona
state which is not reputed for its great
uh support of academic freedom by the
way they had uh you know 40 law
professors just protest a speech on
happiness by a friend of mine Dennis
Prager uh recently and they all uh
boycotted his speech and and they
actually fired the woman who invited him
as far as I understand
um so Arizona state is is not uh you
know typically associated with academic
freedom but I do wonder if if his if his
peers in in the physics or astrophysics
Department whoever he may be he realized
that that he can be swayed by perhaps
personal animus and not by you know the
legitimacy of peer review which is the
foundation of the Bedrock on which
science stands so but let me ask you if
not it could be the case that people
react to things like I'll show you now
uh as evidence of well this Avi Loeb
character he is not doing things
properly going to back to New York City
now I will show you uh this video which
is on your website but this was in Times
Square was it not and was this um can
you see this Avi this video Avi love the
search for inter so this is obviously a
promotion for your upcoming book which
will be out today Galileo project are we
not alone so they're complaining that
this type of thing is not proper in
science I say the father
hold on let me let me just let me just
comment before and I want you to have
the the most of the oxygen but uh unlike
Steve Des who's you know what thinks
you're sucking up too much of the
cyanobacterias gray greatest creation
three billion years ago when we as
scientists we have a term in science
which is called science popularizer
you've heard that term our friend Neil
deGrasse Tyson and people like Bill Nye
Etc I always say well that's weird
because there's no such thing as like a
sports popularizer there's no such thing
as a movie popularizer a tick tock
popularizer they're influencers but
they're not popular why is that that's
because we scientists have been given
the greatest script ever written by
Supernatural forces or if you like by
Mother Nature herself and we're the
worst actors we are the worst actors we
don't engage with the public we act as
if we're super brilliant scientists
squirreled away doing specialized things
like insects that cannot be scrutinized
by ordinary plebes and I think we do
that to great great disservice not only
to science but to society because as you
said earlier it gives a misimpression of
how science is actually done science is
done with tons of wrong turns and and
blind alleys and actually most of the
time we're wrong and especially
theorists I have to say that as an
experimentalist because my job is not to
be right or wrong it's to prove people
like you wrong and actually a good
scientist like you will welcome that so
what do you say to people that say you
shouldn't be promoting something like
this it's unseemly obvious don't do this
well I can explain the context it was
very simple on the day that I went to
the Expedition I got a phone call
from someone who said I'm very excited
about your research and I'm offering you
this slot in Times Square and the same
is true about the funding that I got for
the Expedition one and a half million
dollars I said we want to do this
Expedition it's an important one because
it's the first recognized Interstellar
meteor and I a few months later I had a
zoom call with Charles hoskinson who
said you have the money
I didn't do fundraising I didn't
Advocate I didn't approach anyone in
Times Square they take money away from
anybody you didn't steal money right no
this is all donations meaning that
people are inspired by the message
exactly the opposite of what is being
said it's not me promoting myself but me
saying what I think and hearing back
from the public a very loud Echo that
says please continue and that is
explicit in many emails that I get every
day and to me it means the following
that I should continue and because I'm
following the scientific method by
collecting the evidence analyzing it and
putting it in a scientific paper but
while I'm doing it I'm also showing the
public how it's done there is no harm in
doing so and if anyone has issues with
the findings they should wait for the
scientific paper and raise those issues
but not before that because if they say
it must be a stone when it actually is
iron that makes most of the material
then I would call it the Stone Age of
science meaning everything in the sky is
stones and just think about it if they
work on shown the data on dark matter
that we have they would try to fit it
with stones
and suggest not enough matter and say
the data must be wrong clearly that's
the wrong conclusion and when Fritz Wiki
suggested there is another substance I'm
sure these people would just attacked
swiki more actually than they attacked
me when Galileo suggested something
different he was obviously put in house
arrest so it keeps repeating what what
I'm complaining about is that we don't
learn from history we don't let I mean
the entire academic culture was
established on the idea that you give
people tenure so that they can pursue
ideas out of the box try to Pioneer pass
that were not taken before so that we
can gain new knowledge in directions
that we didn't expect I'm intrigued by
facts by anomalies and I want to find
more data so that we can substantiate
the meaning of those anomalies that
should not make anyone sick because
otherwise you are behaving like a faith
based professional someone who knows the
answer in advance and gets whenever the
evidence proves otherwise let's uh turn
back to the book because I want this
book to to sell and to get all the
attention that it definitely deserves uh
but before we do that I do want to point
out to those of you who are meteorite
aficionados that I actually give out
meteorites this is a fragment of uh I am
two no I'm just kidding uh it's a
fragment of a muamu uh that would be
great how much would you pay for a
fragment of a muamu Avi
oh um well it's uh Priceless but um it's
more for the knowledge I I you know I
don't need I I will send it back just
like you catch a fish and you send it
back into the ocean I would send it back
again it's just that I want to know what
it was made of and I don't want to make
any money out of it so I want to share
uh this uh meteorite with my audience I
send them to anybody who's got a edu
email address at Brian keating.com edu
you can get your own meteorite I will
send it to you because I'm trying to
connect young people that are so
inspired by the type of research that
you and I do and actually get them
Hands-On material which we have chemo we
have x-ray fluorescent spectroscopy of
these proving it's real and uh when I'm
on Rogan I'm giving him a fragment of
Mars which you know I'll give you when
you make me you know a 10-year professor
at Harvard someday but um but I want to
show this pattern because if you cut
open this meteorite that I'm holding up
here you will see this following pattern
it's a very very famous uh type of you
know really a signature and imprimatur a
piece of of such an object when cut
across is called a wooden Statin pattern
it's been known since the 1800s and I
believe that these These are sort of
only really processed for things that
are grown or nucleated and crystallized
in outer space because the zero gravity
allows these to be huge huge single
these are single Crystal boundary layers
I think right Avi yeah um so tell me if
you had a spherol and can you cut it
open can you treat it with the acid like
they do here and can you therefore rule
out that it's not some Interstellar
alloy uh made by you know Apple computer
on some other planet
yes okay all right good so I had this
idea I want some credit for this because
I I asked you about this last month that
I I thought it was a cool test so I'm on
the right path and you will see some
images in the paper
um okay and moreover I should say there
is another signature of a meteor that
came through air through through the
atmosphere that didn't originate on the
surface of Earth let's say from some
geological uh activity uh and that is
that there's some elements evaporated
and they are getting lost uh while the
object is heated as it passes through
the air and these are volatiles and yes
in principle you can tell the difference
between solar even solar system
materials that came from outside of
Earth and materials that were made uh
out of you know the crust of the earth
um and then it's because those elements
are lost while the object is heated up
as it passes through air and we use that
by the way we are looking for the loss
of volatiles as a signature of something
that came from outside Earth but we are
looking beyond that at signatures of
something that came from outside the
solar system very good so when I look at
um objects like this as an
experimentalist uh and I know you're
aware I'm not like uh telling you
something you don't know but as Richard
Feynman said you know the first
principle is you should not fool
yourself and the second principle is
you're the easiest person to fool I
wonder Avi can you explain the most
significant systematic effects can you
talk about systematic effects that could
convince you fooling yourself as I've
been fooled many times as
experimentalists what ways do you
preclude or prevent yourself from being
fooled by systematic effects you speak
exactly like my wife
that's exactly what she's a lovely
brilliant woman then obvious what can I
say she married you you know I married
her that's the biggest compliment and
you dedicate the book to her and your
daughters love them and yeah yeah so
yeah um so that's exactly the question
of course for that purpose we visited
control sites uh meaning regions that
have nothing to do with the meteor
and we did exactly the same thing of
collecting magnetic particles from the
ocean floor and the main purpose was to
compare those in terms of their
composition
to those ferals that may be anomalous
that came from I am one the the first
Interstellar meteor and the purpose is
exactly along the lines that you
suggested we need to make sure that the
in the background we don't find anything
like this ferals that are found along
the meteor path and moreover that the
statistics of spheroles found along the
meteor path on top of the background
because along the meteor path you will
also find background but the statistics
should be such that is consistent with
one with the compositions so let's say
you take a hundreds ferals examine the
composition and you know that 50 of them
should be background you should see that
indeed the composition of 50 of them
roughly 50 up to poisson statistics is
background meaning solar system stuff
that you find everywhere and 50 is
unique so that's a way to verify that
indeed uh the surplus of spheros that
you find statistically along the meteor
path is associated with an origin
different than the background so exactly
to your point very good and we're going
to take audience questions that have
been pre-submitted on YouTube you can
submit it at Dr Brian Keating in the
future and you can also submit it to me
at Instagram Dr Brian Keating and
Twitter uh but before we go there let's
talk about a couple of more questions
that I have do you have a few more
minutes okay great so Interstellar
becoming an Interstellar species maybe
you could explain what does that really
mean or can you commit to a prediction
on when that would happen the book is
halfway I would say it's divided into
part three parts and and some is based
on existing evidence written before you
made this Expedition obviously books are
written months and years in advance
um so the this interview was actually a
more novel new in the sense of of
breaking results but nevertheless can
you commit to some of the predictions
that you make in the book will when if
you could say when is your best guess
that we would become Interstellar yeah
so I think it the key development that
needs to be made is to send to space
gadgets or probes that are autonomous
you know we currently use a perseverance
Rover and it's helicopter Ingenuity on
the surface of Mars and this and the way
we operate them is by
engineers at the jet propulsion lab in
Pasadena sending them commands to these
gadgets that's like helicopter parenting
literally speaking we are parenting a
helicopter over there uh what I mean
this would not work if we were to send a
probe to the next star system because it
will take four years for the signals to
get there and four years to come back by
then the mission is over
so you really need autonomous systems
that can think for themselves meaning
having artificial intelligence and I
call these
AI astronauts once we get there and have
ai astronauts that you process the data
around them and make decisions on their
own you know the situation is very
similar to dandelion flower sending
seeds there is no umbilical cord
connecting the seeds to the dandelion
flower
the nature does it in a very simple way
the flower scents the seeds with the
wind and they do their job that they
were intended to do on their own they
don't send information back in much the
same way I can imagine sending AI
astronauts to space that are autonomous
they pursue the goals that we give them
of course there is some blueprint
architecture involved in sending them we
want to accomplish something so one
thing we can do is let them go to places
where they can use raw materials to
recreate Life as we know it including
complex forms of life and instead of
caring you know currently our thinking
is let's put everything that is precious
to us just like Knox uh spaceship you
know Knox Arc in in in the biblical
story he put all the animals there to
preserve them from the great flood and
you can think of doing the same in the
context of a spaceship putting the most
precious life forms on a spaceship so as
to preserve them and that includes
humans but there is a better way and
that is if you know how to print humans
how to print Life as We Know It with a
3D printer if you have a recipe for that
just like a cookbook what you do is send
AI astronauts to another location where
the conditions are similar and they use
the raw materials to produce whatever
you want and it's just like the print
the printing press of Gutenberg that it
would be a huge revolution in the sense
that we recreate what we enjoy having
here on Earth rather than carry it in a
very Brute Force way on a spaceship
being vulnerable to all the hazards of
space like cosmic rays the emptiness of
space no nutrients and so forth It's
better to send technological gadgets to
extend the longevity of humanity so the
way I see it is once we make this step
forward of sending AI astronauts that's
that will be the time when we will go
into Stella so you uh Interstellar
versus interplanetary your our friend
Elon Musk hopefully future guest someday
on the podcast I'd love to chat with him
because he's never actually talked to a
real physicist like you or me as far as
I understand he's talked a lot with Lex
and with Joe Rogan and stuff but but
talking with a peer and he was an
undergrad and a pen in physics
um so I'd love to talk to him but he's
talked about you know making uh
humankind interplanetary
um first of all do I have it right that
you're quite skeptical as am I about
that and second of all Avi would you
like to live forever I have to think
about it but because there are a lot of
uh why wouldn't you why might you know
because for example I don't want my
tenure in Academia to be forever because
I want young people to think freely and
so they should have positions and if we
would live forever then there will be no
open positions right in Academia just as
an example
um also there are some obnoxious
personalities that I would not like to
have you know forever in terms of living
with uh and so I have to weigh the pros
and cons you know for me it's all about
learning I see Life as a learning
experience and I get a thrill by
understanding something that was not
understood before that really is the
meaning of life for me
but why not keep that going in Forever
the question that could be an option I
have to think I I you know that that
would be interesting yeah okay so Elon
elon's not here to defend himself but
he's often said uh and if you keep
pressing him uh it's it's hard to know
why he's doing what he's doing obviously
he owns a chemical rocket company so
that's quite useful uh you know kind of
a market segment for him shall we say
but when we think about living forever
oftentimes I hear on a personal level
people don't want to live forever
there's a saying in Latin Memento Mori
which means remember you're mortal
you're gonna die which is what a
courtesan to the to the emperor of Rome
would whisper to the Emperor as he
walked around the streets around
remember sire you're going to die as in
a way to emphasize the the beauty of the
present moment and so I've often thought
when I hear Elon talk about these things
the question is never answered why
should we want to become an
interplanetary species he talks about it
because he wants to preserve the fragile
spark of Consciousness great but if it's
good for human beings to be mortal for
our time to be limited to May of the S
room to 120 right why is it not good for
Humanity Avi to be limited so to a
finite duration so first I would like to
say that death is not the only way to
maintain modesty and humility I mean you
can live forever and still be modest and
for me the key is because our knowledge
is limited I'm modest trying to be as
modest as possible about what I assume
about the Universe At Large as a result
you know if even if I live forever it
wouldn't change the fact that we are so
ignorant at the moment we we don't even
know what the universe is made of not to
speak about the fact what existed before
the Big Bang what lies inside the black
hole you know some of the most
fundamental questions and yet we award
Nobel prizes to people who just figure
out how much dark matter there is how
much dark energy there is that black
holes exist you know these are primitive
ideas compared to the actual all content
the intellectual content that we don't
know which is what is the dark matter
what is the dark energy what happened
before the Big Bang you know like what
is inside a black hole these are the
fundamental questions that we are
ignorant about so instead of celebrating
the little we know we should be modest
in the fact you know just given the fact
that we don't know so much and then even
if we live forever that will keep us
modest I think now the problem I have
with Elon is different um well obviously
he wants to establish a new place where
humans live and of course NASA is
thinking also about the moon as an
intermediate step before going to Mars
the problem with Mars it doesn't have an
atmosphere if you were to try to live on
the surface you face two problems there
is no uh protection from cosmic rays So
within a few years every human will die
there in spacesuits uh it's not
protected and the second problem is
temperature changes by hundreds of of
degrees between day and night okay on
the equator on Mars you cannot live
under these circumstances much better to
get into caves like those lava tubes and
you know we came from caves on Earth and
we if we go to Mars we might go back to
caves but life could have started on
Mars you know before it came to Earth
and in that case we're just going back
to our childhood home in some way I'm
most curious about going to these caves
and checking if there are any prints on
the walls a prehistoric paintings
because I want to know if anyone lived
on Mars before us but um I agree with
you that just going to Mars is not a
huge accomplishment in the sense that
you know it's just a little bit farther
from the Sun so what's the big deal that
will not preserve Humanity once the sun
in you know more than a billion years
will expand uh because at that point you
know it will even Mars will be too hot
for us the point is we want to be on
perhaps a space station that allows us
to adjust the distance to the furnace
the Sun or we want to go to another star
like Proxima Centauri the nearest star
where the lifetime of the star is you
know hundreds of times or thousands of
times longer than uh than the Sun and
dwarfs most the most common stars are
dwarf stars depending on their Mass they
have a lifespan of trillions of years
and we have one next to us so why not go
there and then we have Security in terms
of the heat input that we get for um you
know trillions of years which is much
safer than the sun the last topic from
the book of my questions and then we'll
take audit my audience questions I'll
read them to you
um is uh revolves around a term that you
coin that's very evocative as many of
your uh what they're called
neologisms uh it sounds dirty but it's
not dirty but uh your neologism space
archeology what does that mean uh and
would that make you if such a field
could be be created at Harvard or
elsewhere would that make you you know
Professor Indiana Jones uh Loeb what is
space archeology I should say that this
relationship to Indiana Jones already
was uh hinted at me when I went on this
Expedition because that was like going
after some lost
uh treasure you know and uh and be and
and I guess it's fair and that's called
being an experimentalist so yeah you
were you were you know at the last class
of my of my freshman seminar at Harvard
in the spring of 2023 I asked the
students you know if we find a
technological gadget on the ocean floor
and there are buttons on it should we
press a button that was my question to
them uh and it felt like Indiana Jones
speaking to the the class before going
on a on a treasure hunt so the answer to
your question is actually related to the
fact that the sun within a billion years
will boil off all oceans on Earth and
most of the Stars like the sun
formed billions of years before the Sun
so by now if there is a planet like
Earth around them by now the planet is
desert just like Mars it had a
civilization potentially like ours but
it's it couldn't stay there uh because
the star boiled off all the oceans on
those planets and so there were lots of
tragedies uh over Cosmic history and we
didn't know about it because the human
species just came to exist over the past
few million years so we haven't heard
those cries for help and the important
point is if those civilizations sent
probes like spacecraft or the type that
we sent like Voyager 1 Voyager 2 Pioneer
10 Pioneer 11 New Horizons all these
spacecraft that exit into the
interstellar space if they did it before
they perished those packages can reach
us but they will belong to a sender who
is not around anymore so in a way it's
just like archeology where or you have
relics from cultures from civilizations
that are not around anymore and that's
the context except instead of digging
into the ground you dig out into space
very interesting and speaking about uh
relics and stuff my brother Kevin my
beloved older brother who loves your
content he sent me this I told him I was
talking to you and he sent me this image
uh which I don't know can you see it now
this is a meteorite that crashed Earth 3
500 years ago during the Bronze Age and
it was immediately carved into an
arrowhead so they made these things
quite uh quite functional this actually
happens a lot in uh to the Gabon
meteorite that I showed earlier with the
women's satin patterns and other things
this is a very hard to get high Purity
Metals uh you know with of of great uh
of great strength as you know most of
them are not quite as strong as I am one
we're gonna find out why in a couple of
weeks a couple days after this interview
Airs of course
um but what do you make of the fact that
like like if Voyager crashes on another
planet somewhere deep in this uh what
makes you think they're gonna you know
not carve it into you know something for
their 10-legged you know 10 footed
ten-fingered uh digits to manipulate
just like our primitive cultures did in
other words are we assuming too much
about these aliens that they're actually
farted what if they haven't gone through
the great filter talk about the great
filter and talk about what you think
they might do to Voyager 1 when it gets
there right so the great filter is the
ability of a civilization to destroy
itself once it gets to a certain level
of technological advance and uh of
course before that point it's rather
primitive now in interstellar space you
might realize there is probably a rule
similar to Darwin's survival of the
fittest in the sense that only those
civilizations that manage to escape from
their planet or send probes that escape
from the planet are the ones to be
remembered uh and uh in some sense
survive at least in memory if not the in
price practice by a self-replicating
props perhaps
so you know it's much more likely to
find civilizations that are more
primitive of course because
uh you know maybe they never figured out
how to live their planet and they would
stay that way and when they see Voyager
they would make tools like the one you
are showing
um one interesting and by the way that's
a weapon of War right there yeah this is
an arrowhead this is a weapon of war
that they carved as soon as they found
it yeah yeah well that's unfortunately
the psychology of humans to
um you know be indoctrinated in zero-sum
games you know we inherited it from the
jungle where we had limited resources
limited food and if someone gets a
banana the other person doesn't doesn't
have it but now we have you know a
reality of abundance in principle
enabled by technology and science and
the the thing that science brings to the
table is that it's an infinite sum game
that the more knowledge we have the more
you know all of us can prosper we're not
taking away anything by gaining new
knowledge you know maybe we're taking
away uh the Peace of Mind of Steve Dash
but that's a price to be paid uh but
Humanity as a whole by gaining new
knowledge by taking uh risks to figure
out things based on evidence we'll get a
better adaptation to the reality and
have a better life and that's the
promise of science
um and I should say the one outcome of
the Expedition is by identifying the
traits the Fingerprints of an
Interstellar object uh one can go back
to all the meteor meteorites that were
documented in history and check whether
any of them has those uh you know
fingerprints um and we don't have
velocity information about how they came
to collide with Earth how fast they were
moving ahead of time we don't have that
because the US government didn't have
their satellites looking at those but if
we identify some patterns in the
abundance of elements in the abundance
of Isotopes then we can go back and
check if any of the meteorites that are
known to us are Interstellar and then of
course you know we might find some
really really unusual objects oh and I
should say Obviously a big object is so
much more valuable than spherols
spherols are just the droplets molten
off the surface of the object but if we
find a big piece we can easily tell the
difference between a piece of a rock and
a technological Gadget that may have a
label made on some exoplanet or may have
buttons on it and yeah to that point
just one more image to show before I
take you into a voyage into my lovely
and beloved audience the most brilliant
audience in the known Multiverse
uh before I take questions from them to
you Avi uh I did just get a very very
exciting piece of data this was actually
uh broadcast somehow uh don't ask me how
I do these things but this was actually
transmitted uh faster than the speed of
light uh to to this uh Studio where I'm
recording the into the impossible
podcast and that is uh this shows
perhaps why we haven't been in touch
with an alien civilization can you see
this Avi this this shows the alien that
you were talking about and uh it's quite
upset he's about to swipe left on Earth
he sees all the wars and famines and
battles and he sees that Arrowhead
meteorite there so seeing the image of
this alien I would be happy if they were
to swipe us left because I don't like
that that's right
let's put it this way it's a mutual
decision it's not just for the aliens to
decide to swipe left on on us we can
swipe left on them yeah although Hawking
thought we should be careful your friend
Stephen Hawking can you comment on what
Stephen Hawking was so nervous about if
the if the Tinder was swiping right uh
Interstellar Tinder
um what was he worried about you had a
great very close relationship with him
uh talk to us about Stephen Hawking and
his perspicacity when it came to alien
civilizations yeah so about a decade ago
Stephen Hawking commented that we should
be careful at the transmitting signals
to Interstellar space because you never
know who is listening and there might be
a militant alien civilization out there
that will come to us and destroy uh
Humanity as we know it now I'm not so
fearful of that because I think that any
advanced technological civilization that
could potentially reach us or send
gadgets that will reach us uh would not
care about us because the journey takes
millions of years with or up to billions
of years with chemical Rockets the type
of propulsion that we use right now
first of all to get to us anything
should have been sent long before humans
came to exist but even if they respond
to some TV commercials that we send out
the
um unintentionally you know we would not
pose a threat to them there are so many
planets around so many stars out there
that you know we will be
indistinguishable from ants on a
pavement and they would arrive to us
just in case they have some interest uh
that goes beyond us we are you know we
tend to think that everyone focuses on
us but my point is out of modesty you
know this any encounter with a more
advanced civilization would be to our
benefit because it's an opportunity for
us to learn about our technological
future about how to get to them if they
arrived to us before we got to them it
means they are much more advanced that's
why I always say when people say oh you
astronomers are you know concealing
evidence and you would never share this
evidence because you work for big
astronomy I always say no you're
actually in completely inverse the
scientists should be the most interested
in this because it would allow you to
circumvent the physics of the 22nd 23rd
through 29th Century perhaps to get to a
level of true understanding of the base
layer of reality I should mention one
caveat that I realized there is the
Rubin Observatory about to become
operational in 2024 and then among many
other things it surveys the sky and will
identify objects coming close to Earth
right and I asked someone who is
familiar with the soft I said that will
it recognize objects like that are uh
coming from outside the solar system and
that person said no actually the
software that we developed to analyze
that data is only trying to fit the data
for objects that are bound to the Sun so
this is just like saying you know maybe
there are things interesting out there
but I will not look for them that's
really a surprising situation and as a
result we are developing the relevant
software with my postdocs
um so I say we need to take matters to
our own hands as scientists if we want
something to be discovered we can't just
rely on others doing the right thing
because very often what our colleagues
are doing is trying to reproduce what is
already known so if we know about rocks
bound to the sun that's what they would
look for the last question I want to get
into before we turn to our uh our
audience questions is is really you know
kind of this
this ultimate thing where we have you
know the the conflicts that are plaguing
us on Earth I I always phrased it until
recently Avia I said you know the
problem is that what happens below the
Von Carmen line stays below the Von
Carmen line uh in that we have nuclear
you know a nuclear winter which is uh
atmospheric event covid-19 respiratory
you know pandemics propagate in the
atmosphere below the Von Carmen line and
of course you know there there's uh no
shortage of things to be uh paralled
imperiled by global warming which is
obviously of below the Von Carmen line
phenomenon uh to this you added Ai and
so I don't know how to segue that into
my list of Von Carmen line uh pertinent
things but maybe some not everything is
needs to fit into my my rubric uh after
all but um I want you to answer the last
question you know is kind of you know
when you move discussions like this from
the Shadows it can provide a wake-up
call all it can you know kind of be a
slap in the face a diagnosis a prognosis
like you might get from a from a real
doctor not like the two of us
um but uh but tell tell me Avi you know
what sense could this be a wake-up call
for Humanity to tackle the great
problems as I say that exist below the
non-carman line well once again coming
back to the Old Testament the Bible you
know um it is said there that the God
created humans uh in its image we are
creating AI in our image and we are
startled at what we find it's just like
looking at the mirror and saying look at
this face to me sorry they interrupted
to me it's like when I talked to one of
my kids and they realize something
whether it's about YouTube or whether
it's about science that I never taught
them I'm like how do you know this you
like uh yeah you didn't learn it for me
I guess there are other teachers that
they learn from well the problem really
lies in education in the sense that we
you know obviously when we have kids we
don't want to expose them to what
happens you know on the street like all
the crime and but what we do with these
AI systems is we train them on the
Internet which is not different than the
street uh in the sense that you know
very often social media amplifies
negativity amplifies biases amplifies
racism and as a result if you train
these AI systems on whatever is out
there you will not get good behavior
even if it pretends to be good behavior
behind your back it may not be and the
way I see it is just like educating kids
you want to limit the training set to
what you want these systems to be like
in the future you want to give them the
values that you appreciate that's
exactly the purpose of the education
system that's why we send kids to
schools it's so that they will gain
knowledge of things that we want them to
emulate to use in the future and the
same should happen with AI there should
be some regulations about what materials
these systems can be exposed to and we
should train them or in a way even on
artificial text you know we can write
the text that we want them to follow
rather than put them in this wild west
environment of the internet which is the
mistake we are making right now because
um when we see what happens as a result
you know it doesn't look uh really
helpful or satisfactory and it makes
some people upset and it could create a
crime and also in the hands of the wrong
governments it could lead to
catastrophes so it's really all about
limiting the scope of this amazing
technology that we are developing I see
it as a risk I I don't think that
Washington DC pays enough attention to
it because they lack the technical
skills obviously the corporations are
trying to make a profit and the public
is excited because they can do things
that they couldn't do before
I'm not so worried about it taking jobs
because that was always the case with
new technologies you have to adapt to
the changing reality but it's more about
risks to society once you expose these
systems to negativity that it finds on
the internet and
um in principle it could fool you
because right now the number of
Connections in gpt4 is similar to the
number of synapses in the human brain
you get the system which with similar
complexity and once we go beyond that
phase of course we might not be able to
understand at all what how it gets to
its conclusion so we have to regulate uh
how we train it and how to incorporate
it into the legal system that's the
other thing that we don't have laws that
deal with uh crimes committed by AI
systems and one way to deal with it is
if the AI system is still in the
training phase it remains like a kid and
in that case you blame the the parents
the manufacturers the trainers for or
any crime committed but if the system
becomes autonomous self-learning and
completely independent of the training
set then you have to somehow punish the
system by taking it out of this
operation you know just not allowing it
to be in society maybe retraining it
like I mean that's the whole idea behind
prisons that you try to retrain
criminals we need to adapt to this
reality and by the way right now
philosophy departments still teach
ancient Greeks uh I think that you know
since Asian Greeks the great
philosophers did not have computers at
the time we should instead teach Ai and
the ethics of AI it's about you know
philosophy of the future not philosophy
of the past that we should engage in
because we have new challenges many of
them are philosophical about ethics
about how humans should interact with AI
we see the damages from social media to
the mental health of the youngsters so
it's just because we are careless with
these new technologies we let the
commercial businesses develop them
without the guidance and that should
come from philosophy departments
actually very good avi okay we've
reached the final segment we're going to
ask a bunch of questions maybe we could
do these rapid fire you've been so
generous with your time but I know
you've got uh things to do after this
interview so I wanna or just be thank
you and express my hakara tatov to you
uh first question comes from Timothy
O'Brien six on YouTube uh updates on the
telescope You're Building have you been
constrained At All by the US government
so far the messages I got from the US
government are all supportive and
encouraging in fact some Representatives
came to my home and we showed them what
we are doing and it's all in the open
and right now we have one operating
Observatory at Harvard University
with infrared Optical radio and audio uh
capabilities and we are creating the
machine learning software that will
analyze objects in the sky and classify
them into non-familiar objects like
birds drones balloons airplanes so this
system is now being perfected in the
coming months and we are already in the
process of creating copies of it and
placing them in various locations we
have interest from five donors to make
copies we need many more we want to make
tens of such systems maybe a hundred and
so we need more donations to to proceed
in that direction we also have a lower
cost system that we that was developed
at Wellesley College by one of the
collaborators on our team of Galileo
project that Professor Wes Waters I
would say that we are at a very
important juncture right now of starting
to collect data making more systems
placing them in interesting locations so
stay tuned for the coming year and of
course there is a NASA report about to
come out and my expectation is that they
will say that a scientific inquiry of
the type that is being followed by the
Galileo project is what we need so next
question comes from a listener on
uh Twitter or a fan of ours on Twitter
uh and his name is Zagros sex
Vision I can't pronounce it it sounds
like a Hungarian by the way Avi do you
know that uh they said once that aliens
had been discovered already and they're
called hungarians right that's the old
old joke okay anyway and I'm part
Hungarian so I gotta take credit for
that okay Brian you once asked Avi I
think this is in our first interview
what would convince him that omumua
isn't an alien craft and his response
was something along the lines of if we
sent one of our crafts to check it out
and it turned out to be a rock is that
has that changed is that unreasonable to
try to do such a thing yeah I mean it's
really we can't do it now because it's
too far away we can't see it you know
it's really all about the quality of the
data that would convince us one way or
another and what I'm focused on right
now is finding the next dating the next
um with the Rubin telescope and getting
more data on it and of course looking
for Interstellar meteors these are
objects that came from outside the solar
system and they collided with Earth and
we currently have the one that we
explored that we have another one that
we might explore in the near future uh
next comes from Awakening to reality how
have they addressed the Papua New Guinea
results being upset with them over
removing valuable materials as I
understand Avi it's like 30 grams worth
so oh no
even less than that because each of
these ferals is less than a milligram
and we had the 700 of them so it's less
than a gram in fact it's outside the
territorial Waters of Papua New Guinea
and we were in contact with the PNG
government when we organized the trip
for eight months and going all the way
to the top level of the PNG government
and they realize there is no commercial
value there is no biological context the
value to this material that we are
trying to collect and so they basically
um directed us for a partnership with
the University of Technology in Papua
New Guinea which we have right now and
we I just had a visit by Dr Jim Lam who
is the head of uh mining Engineering in
the University of um uh technology in
Papua New Guinea and we are
collaborating we gave him some materials
so it was all a result of someone who
was not in the loop that was talking
about it as if we took but in fact we
went all the way up to the highest level
of government when we coordinated this
visit they were fully aware of it they
had no issue there it's just academic
you know the search for spherols from
meteors was done many times before in
the history of geology and oceanography
and there is no uh there was never
legally there is no legal issue here so
um okay last two questions
from the audience one comes from Twitter
uh someone named Gonzalo Chavez and he's
asking about a Ukrainian study that has
claimed to record spinning objects and
luminous objects
um and he claims an open source Galileo
equivalent project has recorded similar
but Avi said they are artillery can you
comment on whether or not you're uh you
know findings on that have changed at
all in the last eight or so months since
we talked last yeah so the most
important thing in science is Brian you
know very well it's not whether you
detect things it's how the signal that
you detect compares to the background to
the noise
so it's all about signal to noise ratio
and when going to Ukraine one has to
realize there is a lot of noise why
because it's a war zone
so you first have to calibrate the noise
meaning bullets artillery shells drones
balloons all used for you know military
purposes including Espionage and until
you understand the background the
elevated level of noise there would make
you be fooled you would think that
you're seeing something unusual but in
fact it's just noise so it's not about
claiming to see something it's about
seeing something that is completely
distinct from the environment that you
live in now what did this astronomers
report about for example they reported
about dark objects dark objects at a
distance of about 10 kilometers moving
at 15 kilometers per second having a
size of 10 meters and I said well how do
you measure the distance and you look at
the paper and they measured it in a way
that was quite approximate and I said
okay well if it's approximate then the
distance must be smaller because if you
had an object moving faster than the
Escape speed from Earth at the distance
of 10 kilometers and it was you know 10
meters in size it would create a
fireball that's what a meteor is okay
and you can't avoid it if you want it to
block light and be dark it must also
interact with the molecules of air so I
said there should be a fiber it cannot
be a dark object therefore since it's a
dark object it must be closer and if it
was 10 times closer it's a one meter in
size and it's moving at one and a half
kilometers per second that's roughly the
speed of artillery shells or if you
bring it closer it could be a bullet and
so without having precise distance
measurements you can't inference people
often say well maybe it's new physics
and I say well to figure out new physics
you really need Exquisite data you can't
have incomplete data and argue it's new
physics that's not acceptable in science
so two things one you don't want to go
to noisy environments because you will
be fooled more often and second you want
to have Exquisite Data before arguing
for new physics which is clearly implied
if you claim there is no Fireball it's a
dark object moving at 15 kilometers per
second and then there was one object
that they did identify distance to from
two stations that was a bright object
they found the distance that is similar
to the distance of satellites and spy
satellites should be common in that
Arena or communication satellites maybe
it's Elon Musk says that's right yeah it
could be uh you know he's starting up a
new a successor to starlink now that
it's uh already obscuring all of our CMB
bands at low frequencies
I want to thank you for being such a
gracious multi-time guest on the on the
podcast we look forward to your upcoming
appearance when you'll discuss the
results of the paper on the chemical
compositional alloy technological
content of the of the newly disc
discovered spherols after multiple
independent you know randomized
controlled trials and all the safeguards
that I know you're employing uh it's
just a great thing Avi if people want to
donate uh financially to the project are
there opportunities for small donors I
know I know your doorstep is very
crowded with billionaires that come to
your doorstep so you know you that's why
you haven't invited me there but but I
would like to uh also solicit as you
know in the Jewish tradition of sadaka
it's most important actually to get more
small donations and big donations so is
there a venue that people could support
you obviously it's not you it's the
problem yeah is there a way for small
donors to contribute and have a stake in
the outcome financially yeah definitely
not me because we had a conference
celebrating the second year anniversary
of the project and one of the
participants came to me at the end and
gave me a check of five thousand dollars
which I immediately cashed uh with the
administrator of the Galileo project and
it was put into the research fund of the
Galileo project but we do have a button
with the label supporters on the Galileo
project website at Harvard University
and you can just follow the instructions
there and if it's a small donation if
it's a big donation more than ten
thousand dollars then you can email me
of course and I will direct you to
um the relevant people at the
development office at Harvard University
well we started off the conversation
talking about the Voyager record and
this gentleman here uh Carl Sagan I want
to end with it as well pertinent to this
book uh which uh so uh such a delight to
read it's a it's an incredible work of
scholarship as well as a detective story
an adventure story a story of uh of the
Israeli Indiana Jones and he Carl said
the following about books he said a book
is made from a tree it's an assemblage
of flat flexible Parts called leaves
imprinted with dark pigmented squiggles
one glance at it and you hear the voice
of another person perhaps someone dead
for thousands of years across the
Millennia the author is speaking
directly and silently inside your head
directly to you writing is perhaps the
greatest of human inventions Binding
Together people citizens assistant
epochs who never knew each other books
break the shackles of time proof that
humans can work magic so Avi another
magical book uh has uh has been
delivered by you not through gravity or
Interstellar propulsion but nevertheless
I encourage everybody to pick it up and
actually the audiobook uh is due out uh
as we speak and then you can actually
have the voice you know a literal voice
inside your head right and it's not made
of any tree so it saves the trees and I
should say we should all be waiting for
a letter in our mailbox that has a
postal address from outside the solar
system Avi I can't wait and you be the
first person I would call if that
happens to show up here in Southern
California avilob uh Professor bear
professor at Harvard University author
of so many wonderful books and papers uh
I want to thank you for spending so much
of your time with me and I wish you the
best of luck with this book thank you so
much it has been such a great pleasure